a dictatorial system as you have time on
your side so yeah they can first of all
as you'll probably tell us better than
we know China is gonna be funding
election campaigns in the United States
but for sure right and they can just
wait for this president to go and then
they find someone who's weaker right to
to cave to cave to their demands right
and if you think of the ongoing
impeachment trial I think that will end
up China is celebrating right it's gonna
be really happy about about Trump
leaving office because edium today China
is a you know is a very it's steeped in
honor culture there's this notion in in
Chinese culture about saving face and
Trump has no shame and he really does
not allow shine at a safe face he he
speaks ill of it he he basically really
rankles China exactly where it hurts the
most and because he doesn't play by the
rules and he's just abrasive so really
annoys China on a level that's almost
visceral culturally and you know the
question for foreign policy experts is
that a good thing you know does China
behave better when we're nicer to them
that's but over the years it's proven
that that's not the case we've we've
been nice to then we've trade it with
them we love them into the WTO they
didn't play nice they never did so
what's you know maybe it's time for a
different sort of tactics I think that's
what Trump brings to the table at least
in China specifically and it you talked
earlier about an axis and allies coming
back to the new Cold War I guess the the
universal constant Jenner called boys
that both parties kind of knew that the
Soviet Union was yeah an adversary right
is that where we need to get to Ducie
over China I think so um and I think you
know one of the most striking things
that to me at least was when the UN was
in session and they wanted to criticize
what was going on in
in syndrome which where the weavers are
being imprisoned and you look at all the
countries that did not sign the rebuke
against China
it was majority Muslim countries
Pakistan did not sign it many of the
Gulf states did not sign it and and the
people that were the most vocal about
the mistreatment of weaker Muslims were
New Zealand Australia the United United
Kingdom the United States you know the
evil West hmm and somehow the narrative
that that they are the ones who are
Islamophobic mm-hmm you know and somehow
the majority Muslim countries even
Turkey and the weakest are of Turkic
descent did not stand up for them I mean
this is like what we living in this
upside-down world right now in a way and
you can see how China because of the
belt and Road initiative has many
countries basically by the balls yeah
because of the sheer amount of
investment they have in in their
countries I mean just today I thought in
the last two days
presidency Jinping was actually in Nepal
because he you know I think was a 500
million dollar investment in Nepal and
and this is a country that's you know
where the Tibet is there and Dalai Lama
got excised and you see the Welcome that
they gave him and he gave a press
conference saying that if huh if you
know if Hong Kong continues to happen
that they will be crushed bodies and
bones
he said that in Nepal and the warm
welcome that they gave him is pretty
much related to the investment that he
was bringing to this country
and and with the bail and wrote
initiative investments in Africa now
even South America that they're
expanding to who knows who's influenced
who knows whose loyalty the Chinese
could buy it's scary
[Music]